tras la llegada de las vacunas de pfizer
y by ante las autoridades libanesas
activaron rápidamente su plan de
vacunación a trabajadores de la salud en
primera línea
debemos vacunarnos porque estamos
tratando con pacientes tenemos miedo de
infectarnos y poner en peligro a otros
pacientes por eso tenemos que hacerlo no
tengo miedo quiero protegerme a mí a mi
familia y a los pacientes con los que
trabajamos durante el procedimiento
médicos y enfermeras recibieron la
visita del primer ministro interino yo
el aula we ya el con ustedes son nuestra
prioridad el sector médico el sector que
cumple con sus deberes y que ha hecho
muchos sacrificios
son a quienes debemos brindarles todas
las protecciones para que puedan
transmitir el mensaje y salvar a las
personas que uno vive se les vive
teletón líbano ha sufrido de un fuerte
aumento de infecciones en las últimas
semanas que ha abrumado su sistema de
salud con más de 6 millones de
habitantes la nación árabe ha pedido
vacunas que hasta ahora cubrían a casi
la mitad de la población 28 mil 500
dosis de la vacuna pzifer variante que
fueron compradas más de 2,7 millones de
dosis reservadas a través del esquema
global kóvacs
y el gobierno negocia actualmente
alrededor de 15 millones de dosis de la
vacuna de astrazéneca el gobierno espera
vacunar al 80% de su población de aquí a
final de año pero el país navega en
medio de una crisis económica desde
finales de 2019 que según la onu ha
empujado a más de la mitad de la
población a la pobreza el banco mundial
que ayuda a financiar el primer lote de
dosis aseguró que monitorear y a la
campaña de vacunación para garantizar
que sean atendidas las personas que más
lo necesitan